you keep saying how excited you are
about this big depression impression
that's coming at yes and you're half
joking hath not but no I'm a hundred
percent [ __ ] serious okay there's no
joke
I've eaten [ __ ] for the last nine years
to put me in a position to capitalize
guys nine years ago when I started
vaynermedia you got your prospective
happy happy first of all I I just want
to thank all of you for being here today
one more time how did it go great so
really what I want to do is just set up
a little bit of a framework of a recap
of everything I've kind of sensed over
the last two days there are mic stands
in four places throughout there to
everybody up there and the bleachers
there's right there so I really want to
go into QA and maximize our time
together but but what I really want to
talk about before I go into that is in
the macro I genuinely believe that this
is the greatest era to be navigating in
the human race I just actually believe
that I I believe that we've made so many
advances but most of all everybody
that's here today has the luxury of
being alive during the prime years of
the internet which is the
disproportionate invention in the human
race we are now you know the internet
was awesome in 1996 but it wasn't at the
scale that it is today and the
opportunities are ludicrous and for all
the disruption that's happening in all
four of these categories that so many of
you are in with all the innovations of
the companies that have the leverage
with referral fees and things of that
nature you too could take the power of
that platform and you could have the
relationship with the end consumer if
you chose to and that's just not how it
used to be it used to be too expensive
to do that it was expensive to build 50
offices it was expensive to give Walmart
you know millions of dollars
put your product on the shelf this is
the moment this is really the moment and
a lot of my passion and the reason I've
gotten so loud
especially over the last two or three or
four years is predicated that I just
know this is the moment I know when you
have the best hand you need to go all in
and the fact that you are even at this
event know about me and/or this space or
this movement is that is a fundamental
advantage there are millions and
millions and tens of millions of agents
and dealers and companies and people
that look like you for a living that
haven't even begun the process of
accepting the realities of the
technology advances in our society so it
would make me super [ __ ] happy if
everybody clapped it up for each other
let's do that again because that was
some tennis [ __ ]
[Applause]
the content is the variable of success
we have an incredible team and I've
heard unbelievable accolades of the
presentations around media and things of
that nature we other people for free you
know you can figure out how to get in
front of people you know pre-roll
YouTube ads for what you do for a living
is something you can look up with a
Google search and pretty much get on
your way right it's the creative that
you put in front of people that is
contextual to the mindset the culture
the target if anything I hope that
everybody leaves this year so many
people came back this year from last
year talked about they started their
podcast they went mall earth just an
enormous amount of success and
beginnings of success throughout this
entire day for me but there's a part of
me that really wants to put pressure
before we go into QA and I'd like you
guys to start lining up if you got
questions let's start doing that because
I want to get into it there's an
enormous amount of passion I have for
people to get excited about producing a
lot more content and when I mean a lot
more something that I got to say to a
couple breakout sessions one of the
reasons I had my team do a fake takeover
of my Twitter account the other day was
I wanted to find a creative way to
figure out if I could post a hundred
tweets a day a hundred and to be very
honest with you that was just a
precursor to me to figure out if I can
do 500 or a thousand the sheer volume of
content that I think will be the
differentiator of the mature
understanding of this social and digital
web is going to be the differentiator
you're not going to be able to continue
to just beat your competitors by knowing
to run Facebook Ads people will catch up
over the next two or three years so I'm
already starting with the thesis that's
gonna help you compete which is your
ability to somehow figure out how to
make 500 or a thousand pieces a month
instead of three there's a lot of you on
your first try on Facebook Ads with one
piece of content converted it's that
underpriced
that remarkable that you were able to
win when you didn't know what the [ __ ]
you were doing so this is a really
important time and I'd love to get into
some very specific questions so let's do
it so don't have my friend a little
nervous don't worry cool
first of all as a Miamian I think it's
really cool that you're here and you
know welcome to the city I think you're
a guy that understands the relevance of
hubs that affect culture and Miami
really is affecting the Latin American
American North American Nexus of culture
which is a big rolling country and I
think it's awesome that you're in on
that um and my question is man you're
winning in like one of the loudest
spaces that's the most wide-open
tournament for anybody to compete in and
I think one of your big differentiators
when I listen to you man that I really
like is that your end goal is to build
an empire of honey yes you're a context
guy right have you looked around is
there has anybody else who's the closest
that's come to building an empire of
honey and what stops how are you you
know like what what are the obstacles
that are coming to come out of that it
sounds like such common sense like what
do you foresee as an obstacle and
accomplishing that so I think there's
probably tons of big businesses run by
nice people like them Warren Buffett
sounds nice like I mean I'm sure there's
plenty that the truth to your question
is I have no idea the amount of time
I've ever spent looking at other people
that's not and by the way I think it's a
good thing for people that learn that
way I love when people go to another
company spend oh wait we do for these
for that reason there's a lot of people
that learn that way but there's a reason
that I got D's and F's I have a
different style of learning and it's not
gonna be looking at oh Nestle did that
or in the early days of Johnson &
Johnson or like that's not how I roll
the things that cook the consequences
that come along with running a business
or what makes it hard is when you create
a nice culture entitlement takes over
it's hard to motivate when you're
feeding everybody and taking on all the
stress you know so there's a there's
always ramifications to a style but at
the end of day for all of you that are
looking to build something if you're not
happy and it's your thing you need to
reset somebody told me yesterday and
forties that they fired every one of
their employees which I thought was
[ __ ] amazing
and like super self-aware like you know
the end so I think that there's a lot of
ways to do this but I just don't
understand how to do it in a way that
wouldn't make you happy I hate conflict
and negativity so why would I build a
company where that is rampid there's no
amount of money that can close the gap
on that feeling for me the end so that's
it thanks brother how how do you
prioritize creating content and creating
that you know videos and social stuff
when a lot of the time is taken up by
like clients and expense inspections and
things like that
first things first which is what's your
ambition right for a lot of people here
they don't have to right and yes and
it's like to me it comes down to how
many hours do you work and what are you
doing within those hours and how much
money do you want to take home if you're
doing really well and you want content
you could hire somebody to film you and
post produce you could write if your
ambition is enormous
you could work an extra hour you know so
this is just about resources of money
and time mapped against your ambition
there's no I can't of course you can
every single person here wastes an hour
every day on dumb [ __ ] including myself
of course so stop doing dumb [ __ ] right
but it started it starts with the
self-awareness that that's the case and
then it depends on how ambitious you are
if you're buying into my model you're
running a marathon I'm talking about
branding and long-term wealth creation
I'm not talking about short-term sales
arbitrage right right so people pick
short-term they want to buy a Lambo
right they want to go on a better
vacation this year that's why they don't
do it which ultimately in this industry
and the four here will lead to the
demise because the only thing left is
gonna be your personal brand I should
have known that was gonna be your answer
but I just figured maybe I don't know
sometimes you have to hear it yeah like
there's so many things that that's like
that's such a typical answer for like
across the board
cuz it's
yeah yeah I know I don't know why I do
like like my favorite thing on my social
is when there's somebody on this campus
because I read them right and they're
like hey Gary Vee you know what
unsubscribe I'm done with you you say
the same [ __ ] over and over I'm like
would you like me to make up [ __ ] I
don't believe in just to mix it up I
mean it's very true but the question is
what what less people talk about is
ambition you know when I talk about
work-life balance I talk about happiness
and ambition there is no right work-life
balance if you if you like
like what like everyone's living a
different life like if you love what you
do it's your hobby like when I was seven
or eight or nine or ten when its snowed
I wanted to shovel people's yards not
build a snowman it's in my DNA it's what
I like so when you love it the hell are
you supposed to do not do it but you
have to know what you're up to my
biggest problem is people's mouths don't
map their actions yeah they're gonna
build a huge [ __ ] brokerage but they
can't find that hour because they have
to watch the English Premier League yeah
oh thanks Gary you're welcome hi Gary
oh man that's very loud hello I'm Ashley
skiing from Atlanta so I'm an extrovert
and I have to like talk it out to make
sure that I'm like comprehending what
the hell you're saying is going sense
okay cool so the chick girlie out there
she was talking about like oh contracts
inspection yadda yadda yep at the end of
the day and I know you're like content
content content I love it okay and
you're like maximize every minute of the
day
you know still have that balance at the
end of it though it's like for me I'm
starting off fully in real estate and I
have a partner who is also my real
estate partner but we have a roofing and
construction company where it all ties
hand-in-hand understood so he's doing
that I'm really full time real estate
yes at the end of it I'm just starting
off and I want to do that content
content content and I don't necessarily
have the cash to leverage all the SH Meg
ba I know that's kind of gross but I
don't know you know like the contracts
and stuff but when you build your brand
like it has to be about you so
so like how do i leverage without maybe
having the pockets deep enough to
leverage properly for all that other
stuff by patience
oh man that's that's I knew it's gonna
be a freaking easy answer I'm an instant
gratification so maybe that's my part
gonna be instantly in trouble yeah
that's a problem yeah
select look let me just tell everybody
what happened and like I like to remind
people about my career
a platform came out called YouTube I say
I think it's gonna be big I start a wine
show I want to promote this wine show we
you know how do I do that I'm not taking
dollars from what we were doing to sell
product I saw a new platform called
Twitter then there was a website called
some eyes but some eyes built was a way
to search Twitter because for the first
year and change of Twitter you couldn't
search anything that was ever tweeted
some eyes had a search engine I used it
for 15 hours a day data if you remember
'no swen i started coming in at like
10:30 because i was up till 4:30 in the
morning because i would stay and work
seven eight nine hours ten twelve hours
searching every wine term chardonnay
pinot noir bordeaux napa of anybody
tweeting anything because nobody knew
who the [ __ ] i was so i read somebody
saying i'm going to Napa today
on Twitter which cos Silicon Valley
right going to Napa today to drink some
Merlot I replied
what kind of Merlot do you like they
replied duck horn I replied
overpriced they replied I would do that
for 15 hours a day and I did it for four
and a half years before anybody knew
what the [ __ ] I was
[Applause]
vaynermedia was started in buddy media's
conference room because we didn't have
enough money to pay for rent I've I
lived my advice patience you know the
money I get it go and reply to every
single person in Atlanta on Twitter it's
free and if you really really really
really really want it bad
you'll stay up to one o'clock in the
morning and do it and if that's too much
for your body listen to your body don't
get sick but like this is the game
either put in the work or you don't
there's a lot of push back to hard work
I'm not on that bandwagon hard work is
the only thing I know that works when
you don't have money you have money
trust fund hit the lotto made it already
use it Facebook Ads don't have money
your hustle
people are starting to try to demonize
hustle here and there in different
pockets hustle is gonna be put on a
pedestal when the world collapses thank
you Gary for putting this on and thanks
again for the advice you gave us last
year
it helped quadruple yeah can you tell
everybody just four seconds of it cuz
it's so real because I remember sitting
in that we had a mix up as a as a
postgame to a keynote and so we met at
an airport hotel we had condensed time
and I just you know it's funny I was
telling you in your wife yesterday like
I knew you were gonna do it it's just in
that short period of time that kind of
financial impact excites me so just for
the benefit of everybody to inspire them
not hearing it for me hearing somebody
who did it sure so my wife who's sitting
over there Keri Shull we run a real
estate team in Northern Virginia Texas
Maryland area and we were already number
one in that area we met with you the
time was condensed but you were very
flexible and you know made it happen
despite the mix-up which I think was a
third party not anybody that's right
with you and we got about 45 minutes and
you know you really dove into what
exactly we needed to put out on social
media Facebook Instagram all of that and
it was it was pretty simple I mean you
could boil it down to just be the
digital mayor of your town
please by the way you know I think I did
it first I'd like an Inman talk in 2009
was when I came up with an improv on
stage I was like just be the [ __ ]
mayor I'm still obsessed with somebody
here filling up the pothole on Main
Street and filming it and making the
whole town love them yeah that was the
example you gave us I want that one so
we went out and did a whole bunch of
series just going to restaurants bars
neighborhoods and filming like a
two-minute highlight reel of what that
bar was about what that restaurant was
about and then promoting it on a local
blog that was paid you know running
Facebook ads to that area and you know
all of a sudden people were it didn't
work for about a month or two but then
all of a sudden people were like and by
the way [ __ ] I'm seeing you everywhere
at that month or two Park is a lot
because this these industries why I'm
attacking it our sales driven and so all
the other voices are like whoa that's
[ __ ] you spent a thousand we didn't
get a sale go back to cold calling tried
and true yeah so all of a sudden people
were like we see you everywhere
everywhere everywhere and like well we
really we cut out direct mail we went
from like 15,000 a month and direct mail
to zero overnight and put it all into
Facebook and Instagram LinkedIn YouTube
and it took about two and a half three
months and then we exploded normally in
December we would do about 20 deals for
12 million and we ended up around 86
deals for 52 million in one month
so my question is and thank you for that
but my question is how do how do we
scale it and make it even bigger and how
do you and when you more and when you're
doing that how do you balance the need
to just put out a [ __ ] ton more but
still be authentic to your voice and
true to your brand because there's a lot
of because I imagine for you like you've
probably got fifteen sixteen twenty
people just working on your personal
brand like how do you
yeah but make sure they're putting out
stuff that matches your voice and what
you want because I post everything and
write all the copy guys I post every
single Instagram post and every tweet
it's me
I write the copy they like when Calum
was filming me today there's even things
I've said where I give him a look so he
can remember to cut out that part
otherwise they watch and look for the
good stuff then it goes into a text
chain with 20 people I approve if I like
it sometimes I like the title they put
at the top sometimes I don't I change it
then I take it there's there's a reason
there's only one post today we've been
busy here it's authentic cuz it's
authentic how do you how do you avoid
you being the the speed bump then you
can't outsource a personal brand it's a
personal brand I don't I'm just working
harder than you so how much how much
time a day are you putting in just
writing edit less in a normal day when I
go take a poop
like there's a reason why a post always
comes in for you guys on instagram
around 8:50
no no I'm not I'm already um it's
because a really good time for me and
you know it's fun to have my it's
honestly and this is about life like
honestly it's fun to have my parents
here I've started speaking less to my
mom in the last year and a half because
I need that five minutes to get that one
post out and that doesn't make me happy
by the way that's just the truth to your
answer the reason you'll see so much for
me at 8:52 9 is that's that little
window I'm in the car right before I get
into the office where I can sneak one in
and I also know that you guys are
starting to get to your day then you're
gonna get something somewhere around
noon one I don't you lunch but like it's
consciously hitting me like [ __ ] I need
to like think about getting another one
out in the next 4 hours but like it's
it's random but like but it's the most
valuable thing everyone's like when do I
do this what I have to do my real job
I'm like you're [ __ ] real jobs
[ __ ] this is the game so are you
actually like on the Instagram app
typing it with your thumbs or you know
like [ __ ] tongue yes yes I'm posting
it me me me yeah like yeah not even know
if they gave it to you and you did it in
a different program or yeah like you
know what day's money Kayla you know
what's funny Caleb was excited about the
K where the [ __ ] are you like 6 7 what a
[ __ ] huge beard okay fine either okay
Caleb actually did a good job I gave him
a compliment yesterday cuz I like the
way he blogs me it's a new look fresh
eyes right indie rock yarn are cadence
me and babban were me and iris were he's
brought a really good element because he
was a big fan and knew a lot of stuff
and there was things that he knew
weren't answered and he's really helping
me answer takes he filmed me yesterday
posting it on the way here for four DS
and he and he got me to say something he
was interested in it I here's what
happens I get a bunch of pieces of
content in my text chain with the whole
team there's clips from the videos cuz
that's why we vlog then I look at the
title like do the right thing why don't
you know that [ __ ] and sometimes I'll
change it sometimes it's great you know
when you're around people you can get
into that but then I watch it and I'll
watch it and then I'll immediately post
it and if I get a call from my
while I'm in the middle posting it when
I'm done I'll have to go back in REE
watch it because I've got to be really
[ __ ] fresh on it right like and then
I'll write the copy and then I'll post
it and then I'll reply that's why I
created Team Gary V that's them
when you get Gary B reply that's me I
heart it that's me so that's how I do it
thank you you're welcome
let me tell you why let me tell you why
coming up to you in the top-right let me
tell you why
bottom left if somebody wants a lineup
um let me tell you why that's so
important to read your comments the
reason I've been able to continue to
come up with [ __ ] is cuz I read comments
the replies to things are the things
that allow me to build on things
it's how I you know it's how I got into
parenting or self-awareness or keeping
up with the Joneses it was just one long
seed - why would I why is every single
person here not doing exactly what I'm
saying that would be something I was
interested in and then I would read and
read him like oh insecurity you know and
just you just keep going down these
paths you must read every comment
you must reply to it you need if
somebody everybody here's trying to
build a huge following the best way to
build a huge following is to actually
give a [ __ ] about your small following a
couple of years ago you gave a talk on
how much money you should be spending on
social where are you at now with the
monthly ad budget of what you should be
doing no matter what as much as you can
humiliate Ford okay I like I like
hearing it from you let me let me tell
you why Facebook and Instagram attention
is grossly underpriced it won't be
forever you know like real estate it
goes up in value it's coming cuz Google
did it how many people here ran Google
AdWords in 2002-2003 raise your hands
raise em high raise em high remember
that [ __ ] it's not the same price
anymore so to me as much as you can
and that means being thoughtful about
what you're saving or spending for your
life so you can pour more into the
business right it's gonna go away as
much as you can but it's content and
media that's where everybody's getting a
little bit caught up everybody's pouring
more media but they haven't made 14 new
44 new 72 new your one new video one new
post away from changing the outcome on
that CAC LTB leads same media spend 33
the 47 year old women in Detroit
different piece of content $8 lead
$4,000 lead the content is the variable
people have committed finally to the
spend to some degree but the people here
that aren't effective on Facebook right
now it's your content suck [ __ ] or your
content isn't contextual against your
media spend but the value is clear as
day and it will go away
thank you you gotta brother you keep
saying how excited you are about this
big depression impression that's coming
in yes and you're half joking that's not
but no I'm a hundred percent [ __ ]
serious okay there's no joke
I've eaten [ __ ] for the last nine years
to put me in a position to capitalize
guys nine years ago when I started
vaynermedia you know what you collect
though you do client service businesses
suck nine years ago I was on fire I just
invested in Facebook and Twitter and
nobody even knew this social like and
the digital I was on TechCrunch all the
time sucks and all these [ __ ] fancy
[ __ ] people are my friends I should
read should have like many of my friends
who are not as on fire as me I could
have raised the 300 million dollar fund
took two points for just running it do
you understand the math on that and had
20% of the [ __ ] backend for being
somebody who just took [ __ ] meetings
and gave out cash to invest hoping
something hit instead I built a business
that sucks [ __ ] I'm not joking at all my
guy I [ __ ] put a decade in to build a
foundation to [ __ ] capitalize because
I want AB on the Jets and when Super
Bowls
all right good so talk to me so you know
children so you know real estate the
limited barrier to entry a lot of a lot
of [ __ ] artists out there you know
director of sports director of red head
book red heads you know there's all
these [ __ ] titles out there but
really the director of red heads know
you know you know what I'm talking about
but you know the housing market is at a
slow down especially in Miami and a lot
of people are trying to fluff it and
talk a big game and though it's great
but no but yes but bottom line is we all
know where the [ __ ] we're at so I don't
know how to get worse exactly thank you
so how well what's your advice to
prepare for that getting worse high in
hash and what's your advice to prepare
in that industry when there's that
standstill by [ __ ] well there's there's
a period of time where there there's a
standstill and then all the flesh people
you know what's happening next right so
maximize cash right now and maximizing
cash comes in two ways there's people
like me who just makes a lot of cash and
there's people like my parents who spend
no cash if my parents that I teamed up
we'd be trillionaires you know so
everybody here can figure out how
they're going to maximize cash for me
for most people who aren't capable of
doing what I'm doing which is just
generate so much it's probably better to
be thoughtful about your spending right
right no I mean look there's there's
that period of stancel you know
everyone's like Oh preciate this doesn't
make a lot of sense to you I value the
depression so much that I've been
waiting for the stamp we I've been in
the standstill for four years I just
know that $100,000 today see what people
do that they're not smart
they they they don't think it's the
bottom yet so they're trying to pull a
couple more shekels out while it's good
right but they don't realize is that a
hundred thousand dollars when it's a
nightmare economic world is worth seven
hundred fifty thousand and they're not
gonna be able to pull out 750 in this
little window so am I happy that I
haven't maximized all my cash
I'm not thrilled am i gonna be super
pumped when the [ __ ] hits the fan super
pumped here's the best part
I'm telling everybody it's gonna happen
like you can do it too it's so black
what you know if you're in your [ __ ] if
you were in your [ __ ] and it sounds like
you're in your [ __ ] in Miami it's not
gonna get better it's over built it's
over leveraged tax implications its [ __ ]
name date this time is gonna be much
lower than in 2008 or maybe not maybe
the current president and the current
atmosphere and whoever else maybe they
decide to put a huge band a - I don't
know what I know is shit's gonna hit
hard so my advice is don't try to get
cute and get a little out Sinnott
maximize [ __ ] cash
god bless right I told Zack to his face
I'm like we got any if he had a big
[ __ ] number and speaking this year I
want the cash yeah once again thank you
so much very what does the coziest [ __ ]
up there is like our deceits that cozy
you don't wanna ask questions what the
[ __ ] going on up there
the hungry people come to the front go
ahead so I think you've just better
chance man this is about [ __ ] go ahead
they are digging into the asphalt I
haven't seen with 12 not everyone is
interesting not all content is industry
in an interesting real-estate as
industry is not always the most
interesting who says oh me right you're
one [ __ ] dude dick I know you don't
get to say
fair enough right but you say I do no no
you do for you right not for the
consumer true enough yeah this is a very
important you know I'm jumping in and
make a joke to make a very big point
some people think it's really boring to
watch men run to each other and play
football I think it's the most
interesting [ __ ] in the world other
people decide watching six episodes of
escaping our Kelly is [ __ ]
fascinating I do not
the audience gets to decide so I keep
telling people here like they're like
I'm not interesting I'm like the only
thing you've got is that you're actually
interesting because you're uniquely you
the biggest advantage everybody here has
when it comes to this concept is their
truth but everybody tries to do what's
the right thing to do and they start to
vanilla themselves so go deeper and
deeper into content as deep as I can get
correct about anything like shrimp today
hurt my ankle post third comments I
[ __ ] hurt my ankle - tonight we're
humans guys we're humans I mean it it's
why reality TV one reality TV got [ __ ]
on social media got [ __ ] on the closer
to the truth the better we like it it's
why we rubberneck it's why we try to
like sit and listen to other people's
conversations it's what we do we're
interested and so we have to talk about
more you know hey here you got a brother
I gotta go catch a plane thank you
[Applause]
your shirt is pretty [ __ ] phenomena
thanks Ryan
from Hawaii hey everybody thanks for
having me I think real estate is moving
towards the Amazon here okay got it
I think it takes 45 days I have my house
sometimes two months I really think you
should be able to walk in maybe fry on a
Monday you get your keys on a Friday
you're good to go and I think that's
where Real Estate's gonna end up maybe
in 10 20 years definitely I would love a
front yeah let me tell you how you're
not chained okay yeah action yeah that's
what black Asian dude when it's me and
him and none of you [ __ ] faces get in
the middle like I'm gonna move in on
[ __ ] Fridays gonna give me the keys
on Friday [ __ ] Monday yeah yeah so well
coming and I want to be on the front of
it good boss
build apps on blockchain and wait seven
years for it to be at scale since you're
young as [ __ ] you know start putting out
content around these thoughts yeah as
you're thinking them through no I mean
that's what I got for you I mean like
like what how are you practically gonna
be at the forefront I'm just right now
tomorrow making house purchases go from
Friday to Monday I don't know you can't
there's too much infrastructure and too
much logistics in the middle in the way
the industry structure right now you
don't have the leverage the only
leverage one can have is putting out
content to create new ideas and get
people to rally behind them and that's
what I would do you know yeah like you
know the tools are not in place yet
right like I want to go to Mars and eat
a fruit cool how mm-hmm
that's really like there's too many
processes and state laws and there's
just too a [ __ ] right now we're gonna
need a human restructure the last two
men restructure was called the internet
it really is in the process of
restructuring the next one will be
blockchain blockchain has the
infrastructure to play out the dream
that you have you're gonna have to wait
good news is you're young right you'll
see it all right but I think you should
start talking about it
Podcast content things like that guys
thank you so much hey guys thank you so
much for watching my video on YouTube I
wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a ridiculously
important project for me and I have a
funny feeling you can help if you drink
wine at all or know anybody that drinks
wine at all please go to empathy wines
calm right now and sign up for a
subscription whether it's a three pack
whether it's a six pack or whether it's
a whole case of each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for club empathy this
project means the world to me that could
really use your support
you